around
great so uh welcome to everyone back to
the afternoon session
um we have a great afternoon plan any
announcements for uh the day still a
social thing at after the yeah great
um good so uh to kick off the afternoon
who's going to tell us about measuring
distribution of the chip drift with
multi-group game keys thanks Michael and
thank you all uh for coming uh
this is the first talk after lunch I'll
I'll keep it light that's the only
reason why it's a light tank just
because it is after lunch
um okay so I'm gonna talk about
um distribution drift how to measure it
there are different uh ways of measuring
it and how does a notion like
multi-group or multi-group fairness or
multi-group guarantees how do they
interact with with uh with this object
uh with distribution drift so
the the fundamental object that we study
is the importance weights of two
distributions so we have a query access
to two different distributions over the
same domain
and we will assume that they share the
same support we will avoid that uh
technical annoyance
um
uh and our uh our access to these
distributions is through sampling so we
don't have any model for these
distributions or external knowledge for
that matter we just have sample access
to these distributions and our goal is
to estimate the importance ways to
estimate the ratio of the weight given
to each point by the distributions and
let's assume it is we're all in the
finite world so these uh objects
actually uh the discrete World these
objects actually make sense
um
so so the uh the importance weights of a
point x is the ratio between its
probability under R and its probability
under P
um and the observation the first
observation that one can make is of
course if we know RN we know P then it's
a trivial uh problem and we can try to
model R and model P separately but we
don't need to do that actually because
what we care about is the ratio we don't
care about the individual distributions
and and uh it may help us
this problem uh pops up in many many uh
different applications it's a very
important problem has a lot of papers
under different names and different
monikers and different communities
um for our purpose I think it's very
instrumental
to think about it as a way to measure or
to characterize just distributional
drift that we see in practice uh for
this uh you can think of p as the
features of uh the population of one
population and rs features of another
population and then uh P may be the
training distribution P May stand for
prior and army stand for real life so uh
we have the training distribution and we
have the target distribution where our
model actually
um
actually live we may want to compute the
um the distance between these
distributions with one number it's a
very natural number that we will use in
this talk uh is the KL Divergence
between these two distributions and
there are definitely scenarios where
this number is being tracked and if it
crosses some threshold then some
decision is being made maybe you want to
relearn the model
um
in the world of causality analysis for
observational data then propensity
scores play a major role and propensity
scores are essentially importance
weights in disguise
um
this is actually the motivation it's
funny it's a little bit kind of amusing
to think about it for for us that worked
on it from this distance now looking
back but the original motivation for
this entire work was anomaly detection
where
um
P may be a distribution of measurements
of say a data center uh when you know
that it works normally and R may be the
measurements of the last month and the
importance weights could be a way of
estimating whether you have seen new
points in the data that you may want to
look at and consider as anomalies so it
is an important problem
and the question is what guarantees can
we actually hope to make and the first
observation
um is that we can't hope to efficiently
compute the importance weights exactly
and there are many uh there are many
examples to show that you can't do it
um I think an example that is
computational and not information
theoretic but it could be uh it could be
done information theoretically as well
it's just to think of one distribution
as being pseudorandom and the other
distribution as being truly random and
now uh the differences between these two
cases are very big uh right
um assuming that X is samples from R
then if it's uniform then the importance
weights are one it's the same
distribution it's pseudo-random and the
support is much smaller and the
importance weights would be very big
um
so efficiently uh hoping to uh to get
pointwise accuracy is impossible
um and you can even won't get any
non-trivial approximation so the notion
of approximation ratios is not is not a
fruitful Direction here
um
and the question is whether we can have
any sort of guarantees if not on points
then maybe on sets and on groups of
people
and if this starts to ring familiar from
previous stocks you know in previous
stocks we didn't have the importance
ways we had the beige optimal uh
predictor so it was kind of the same
story and indeed you'll see a lot of
parallels uh in the in the Chain of
Thought between that case and and this
case
so before I start with our work I want
to just uh since I will show some
experimentation I want to just present
how does the state of the art look like
what do the algorithms that people
actually use uh what do they look like
and
this is a a very popular algorithm it's
not the only one but but uh it's it's
good to look at it and to understand it
so what do we have here
we come up with some uh simulation of r
so Q is so this would be an important
weight our our uh our um
um approximation of the importance
weight and therefore when it's
multiplied by T we get some distribution
so let's assume it's normalized to be a
distribution which is q and we can think
of this queue as our approximation of R
so we we re-way P the best we can and we
get this distribution Q which is our
approximation of R and we hope to get a
really good approximation we hoped you
to be as close to our as possible say in
KL Divergence so this is and and if you
write it down you will see that this is
actually an optimization problem and you
can solve it
um
you may think of other variations uh you
can take other Notions of distance or
other uh parametric family to choose
your importance weights from doesn't
have to be uh Gibbs distributions
um but um
fundamentally the algorithms look like
that and there are many of these there
are like hundreds of papers around this
kind of
um framework of Designing algorithms
um what is the guarantee of an algorithm
of this family well
if the exact if the truth if the
importance ways happen to fall in this
parametric family then you find it
hooray
um and if it's not then you get the best
in the exact sense that this algorithm
prescribes whatever that is right you
get the exact closest in KL Divergence
from that particular parametric family
and you can do with this guarantee
whatever you can do with it it's I mean
it's
mostly not very meaningful in most cases
okay
so we want to have some semantic yeah
foreign
[Music]
first of all it turns out an experiments
is fairly
um efficient is is good in practice this
is Gibbs
um
this gift distribution so it's a very
rich family and then
uh the KO just means that you have this
expression outside when you take the log
so it's just it's a nice optimization
problem to write I don't I don't have a
good answer on why particularly these
choices of distance and uh and
parametric family
it's the math of this particular
algorithm is very nice it's very easy
yeah I think there's some like theory
that justifies it by the maximum entropy
oh yeah yeah
so this you're right this particular
thank you this particular framework if
you look at the Dual of it then it's uh
then you can then there's a very
um natural interpretation of the duel
it's the maximum entropy distribution
that is multi-accurate
um so
um but um definitely you can look here
instead of exponential form a linear
form and that's also a pretty popular
algorithm
okay so we will talk about sets and what
is the role of set so again this thing
should look familiar for you so sets are
they have like a dual role in our uh in
our narrative they are they represent
subpopulations of Interest so these are
the sets that we want to have guarantees
for
um so if it's population it would be
some cross section of age gender
ethnicity whatever and that's in our
data but they also capture our
computational power right these sets are
exactly the sets that we hope that we
can recognize formally
uh that we can at least weekly
agnostically learn so we will have this
family of sets which is family of models
it's the same thing and they have this
uh dual role in in the type of
guarantees uh that we have at least from
a
um high level right from a kind of
semantic point
okay so we have our two distributions
rnp we have a family of sets
um
in previous talks when we talked about
models then the models were functions
um I will simplify things and really
think just about just about sets
um
and we have our estimate for importance
weight so what do we really want in life
right so when we have a group a set that
we care about
and we see that our importance rate is
high on average for this group well we
wanted to mean something we wanted to
actually have some guarantee that the
importance waste is high in real life
and maybe vice versa if we have a set
that it's measured under rnp are very
different then we want some guarantee
that at least the average importance
waste that we will give to uh points in
this set will be high and this is
exactly the type of the type of
guarantees that we have
so if the measure of
of the set C is high on R compared to p
then we hope that our expected important
weight will be high on the set and on
the other hand
if the true importance weight is high
I'm sorry and on the other hand if our
expected importance rate is high then we
hope that the true importance weight is
also high so put in uh put in uh more
math terms this is the kind of guarantee
that ultimately we will achieve
um I'm not arguing that this is the best
guarantee one can hope for or that this
is a guarantee that
um if I ask you to write a guarantee it
would be the most natural thing that you
would write immediately but this is what
we can prove so I'm arguing for this one
um so again let me uh let me just uh go
through it again uh with words because
it's a little bit uh subtle to see
though it's actually pretty natural when
you look at each inequality here
um
separately so the first inequality what
does it say it says in some sense that
we are conservative if we take our
importance weights and we average it on
R right we think of p as the power
distribution and R as the real
distribution so R is the distribution we
actually observe
and we look at the expected importance
weights for a set we are conservative if
this expectation would be smaller than
the real average importance weights so
if we are high it just means that the
truth is even higher
but I mean this could be satisfied just
by saying zero all the time right so we
have a guarantee from the other side and
that guarantee is just
the measure of this entire set
uh the ratio of the measure in this
entire Set uh um the measure of R and
the measure of P right the ratio of
these two measures and
um nicely if you play around a little
bit then the left hand side is also the
expected
um truth of the importance weights so
the expectation of w star of X where the
expectation is taken under P instead of
under r
so
um
and it's another interesting thing to
mention is that the external inequality
the fact that this is smaller than this
that follows from this guarantee is
actually an application of Jensen's
inequality hopefully in the right
direction uh so it's it's complexities
so we call this a sandwiching bound
um
and um
and
we call this a sandwiching bound and
this is the guarantee that we can have
four important slits now if you take the
log of this guarantee you will get a
guarantee over KL Divergence and this is
what I will
present next
um
so what is the KL Divergence the KL
Divergence between these C distributions
of uh like a nice way to think where
kale Divergence is one of these things
that could be described in a million
different ways
um
and I think a nice way to think about KL
Divergence for this particular context
is just that it's the expectation of the
log of the importance rates where the
expectation is taken under our so
um uh so it's very natural to think that
the inequality or the guarantee that we
had in the previous slide would actually
translate to a guarantee and the KL
Divergence itself
um
and there are some choices that one has
to has to make here right if you have a
um
a uh
uh you don't have W star itself you have
some estimation of w then now the
question is how do you use this in order
to actually give an estimate for the
importance way so for the KL Divergence
or for the conditional KL Divergence for
a set and there are two ways in which
you can do it you can just replace the W
with the w star and take the expectation
of the log or you can
um take uh as we did previously take the
simulation of r
and just think right Q is the simulation
of our
um uh by the importance ways that we
actually computed and think of that as
if it was our and you would think maybe
it's the same and one of the nice things
that our algorithm can guarantee is that
indeed it is the same but it doesn't
have to be so for other algorithms these
two these two estimations of the KL
Divergence they don't have to actually
provide the same number you would think
that if they provide the same number
it's a good sign and I would agree and
indeed the algorithms that we will
present they show the same sign
and now
um
what does so let's think of it since
it's the same let's think it's uh I
think it's easier to think of the
distribution to you so we actually
create a distribution queue that is the
simulation of r
and what these
um these two inequalities here which we
call a fair attribution of KL Divergence
is essentially like taking its morally
like taking the log of the inequalities
that I showed previously it essentially
says
um that the KL Divergence that we
compute q and P will not be too big it
will not overshoot the truth that KL
Divergence between rnp
and the second inequality says that at
least in klq is closer to R than it is
to p
so one way one way to think of it is
that
um
what we actually want is to
to improve over over P itself right so
we get closer to R
uh from P but simultaneously for all
sets so we have some improvement
guarantee that is simultaneous to all
the sets in our uh in our uh in our set
system in C
um
all right it just means that Q is
between so this is actually and the way
I won't show the proof but if you
remember uh those of you were here
yesterday and was we're very very Alert
in parikshit stuck then uh he mentioned
the Pythagorean theorem right he
mentioned that the
um the the multi-calibrated predictor in
his case lies in KL Divergence exactly
between
um the set C and the in that case the
Bayesian optimal predictor p and in some
sense this is exactly what we show here
we show that this simulated distribution
that we have q it lies in between R and
P in KL Divergence
and it lies in between not just as
distributions but even when we condition
on the set so we can kind of improve
we're like in between these two for all
the sets in our set system
simultaneously I think this is a way to
to understand uh these inequalities
so let's uh
stop a second and and kind of reflect
what what did we say until now so
we sidestep the lower bound per point
right because if we want to have
semantic guarantees we can't argue on on
uh on a point per Point basis
uh that that inequality is obvious that
you can you can prove that without uh
even in that like pseudo-random case
that it works
yeah the sort of random case all the C's
are kind of uh the student random case
is actually it's a good case to think
about because all the C's are identical
in the pseudo-random case when you look
at C you don't see when you look at your
stats since it's sort of random you see
the same thing what if what if the two
random set was one of the sets then you
could use it in uh
yes
if it's in the set then or you know
right so the pseudorandom the example
for student random is a nice example to
think about in general I think in
everything we we talk now because it
shows that the computational approach
to uh objects that are fundamentally
information theoretic in nature is is
almost necessary right I mean you want
to say it doesn't matter if it's
suitorandom right so so that's the way
to to argue it okay
so uh so this is uh the quality is with
respect to a set system and
um the Divergence is attributed whatever
I mean in the precise way that we we
described uh to subpopulations
uh it's not tied to a loss functions
it's not an optimization problem right
so so all of these themes you've heard
in the previous talks as well and by now
this should just feel like like
multi-calibration right it just feels
like like the stuff that that we saw in
previous talks but this is an
unsupervised problem we don't have
labels uh it's uh we don't have a base
optimal predictor so
um
but that's the right approach and I will
I will show soon how to use it so let's
uh just have a very very quick uh
refresher uh like one slide refresher to
what is calibration and what is
multi-calibration you've seen
um this several times uh today and
yesterday
the only thing I want to point here is I
made uh the simplifications where C is a
set
and the prediction
um is a
um is in a discrete value so I'm
actually like this equal right so think
of the prediction as being either 0.10.2
or 0.3 and so on and the sets are are
really sets they're they're zero or one
and now we just have this standard uh uh
definition where calibration is we want
to be given a label which is binary zero
one one would be correct on expectation
conditioned on the prediction itself and
multi-calibration is to be calibrated
when we also condition on being in any
one of the sets in our set system
this is all there is to it
so now how do we use this concept for
importance weights in a very
actually in a natural uh in a natural
way so we create the following
supervised uh learning problem
um
we just take a mixture of these two
distributions
so you think of the learning algorithm
the learning algorithm sees a an X
with probability half this x was sampled
from p and was labeled
um zero with probability half
best X was sampled from R and was
labeled one and now what we want is just
to try to differentiate between these
these two and if F star is now
the base optimal predictor for this
um supervised learning problem
then the optimal important weight is
just the ratio of f of x and one minus f
of x right it's just a connection
between odds and importance weights so
so when phrase through this problem
there is a natural correspondence we can
just say that now the importance weights
are multi-calibrated if the predictor
that derive them or if the predictor
that is tied 2W through this formula is
multi-calibrated
and this also would uh give you a very
very strong hint as to how one would
compute the multi-calibrated
you're saying this is a new definition
yes yes it's not the way it is in the
paper okay but
historically this paper was uh before
the other papers so uh this is the the
right way given given the body of work
that we have now this is the right way
of defect
you're not going to condition on say the
uh so
and now the theorem that we can prove is
exactly what uh you know what I've been
uh arguing from the beginning the
conditions that I showed that uh begin
whether it's the sandwich in bounds or
the
um
the sandwiching balance either is for
the importance weights or for the KL
Divergence both of them are achieved
um if the importance weights are
multi-calibrated with a caveat of course
of a lot of fudging of epsilons around a
lot of Errors uh that needs to be
carried but
um morally it's the uh it's the
inequalities that I've shown
all right
um okay I have a few minutes
so in the five minutes that I have I
want to talk a little bit about
implementation and about the experiments
that we uh that we ran
so
um Michael described uh an algorithm but
at the beginning so there and I want to
show a slightly different algorithm that
is maybe more natural uh in the case
where uh C's are indeed sets
um and what you can do is you can
partition uh the space of X as
iteratively by the set c as best as you
can
to try to differentiate between rnp
while also emerging partitions that have
the same average value and kind of a
greedy Manner and I will show a slice if
this is kind of not clear I Will Show a
slide soon and there are there are
details and details on how to actually
do it uh
the point I want to make here is that uh
the algorithm ends up to be a variation
of an older algorithm called boosting by
branching
um
that somehow
um when it was designed by Kirsten
Mansoor and Sir McAllister
they showed some specific properties of
that algorithm and maybe they had a
sense that these algorithms are in a in
a very precise way stronger than maybe
General boosting
and
one of the things that we show is that
these algorithms indeed give a
multi-calibrated predictor so they are
indeed in a very precise and profound
way stronger than
say a the Boost
and this is how an algorithm would look
like for this part particular case and
this is indeed how it was implemented so
what does this come to show you have a
distribution you have your your
distribution of labeled examples right
in our case it's the mixture between uh
PNR
and now you just try to find a model
that separates them so initially they
were half half right the labels were
half of them all you try to separate
them as best as you can so you find the
best uh the best model and you separate
them to one group and then you look at
the labels and you see that in that
group the probability the proportion of
of label one is 0.2 and in the other
group The proportion of label one is 0.7
so you made some
uh advancement
um and then you just continue
iteratively on each one of those to try
to partition them uh where if two
partitions end up in the same
probability they are effectively merged
right so for this cell there are
multiple paths that could reach that
cell
um and at some point you reach a point
where you can't partition anymore
and that's when that's when it ends so
it's a very simple algorithm it's simple
to implement
um as well
um and it it works beautifully and
there's a lot of rounding to do and
decisions what to do with sales that
don't get a lot of points and so on but
this is
extensions
so so let's so we we wrote this
algorithm and let's let's just see that
uh that it works because
somehow it does and that's that's a nice
that's a nice thing to to observe
so this is a
um
a synthetic data set so let me that we
produce let me explain what it is
we have a mixture of gaussians
um so p is a mixture of gaussians and R
is the same mixture of gaussians only
shifted just by a tiny bit
so
what you see here is them superimposed
one on top and the other but if we kind
of zoom in we see that each one of those
is shifted just by a little bit and
the nice thing about this is that you
can easily imagine that these are just
separate very separate and distinct
um populations in your data set that
they were somehow all shifted and you
want to
um you want to see if you how do you
attribute the KL Divergence uh to these
different populations
and another nice thing about this
particular data set is that since as you
can see from the diagram since they are
so well separated
um you can actually compute the ground
truth or a very good approximation for
the ground truth of the KL Divergence
which in this case is close to nine if I
remember correct
um and now what you see here is several
algorithms I would just focus on our
algorithm which is the top one and on
the algorithm that I presented at the
beginning the um the maxent or the KL
minimization which is this one which is
the red and the way to interpret this
thing here is the line is just the
average the total KL Divergence that you
computed so as we said the truth is nine
uh but our algorithm where the model set
is random first subject five it
interests you is something like six
point something and this is four point
something so we we find way more
Divergence than them but that's that's
not I think the main point the important
point is that every marker here every X
is the KL Divergence of one of the
subpopulations
and what you see is that in our case we
are very concentrated because we are
very good for all those subpopulations
separately and this is kind of the
fairness or the multi-group aspect of it
while all the other algorithms have like
wild subpopulations where they are
mistaken and
um another way to see it
is through this diagram so this just
focuses on some select pairs of of
subpopulations and we just color them by
the importance weight so you want to see
a nice separation of the two gaussians
and in a multi-calibrated algorithm you
see that they all look more or less fair
or the same while in this one even
though a priori they're all the same
like there's no real reason to be better
on one subject population than the than
the other it's just kind of
the internal randomness of the algorithm
probably but you see maybe here this is
a pretty bad classifier for this
particular pair here it's a pretty bad
classifier so you see a variation in the
quality of the classification which If
This Were Real people I think is you
know it feels like fairness it feels
unfair
um so this example is synthetic and we
also know the ground truth but the the
nice power of theory and I'm done in 30
seconds the nice power of theory is that
it gives us guarantee even when we don't
know the truth right that's so that's
the next experiment
for the next experiment we just computed
the KL Divergence between a weather
measurement of a random hour in Las
Vegas in the 80s and a random hour of
Las Vegas in the 2010s
um separated by months and you see a
huge difference you see a wild number I
think like 2.5 is very high KL
Divergence so
um
now you know that the algorithm is
actually a lower bound you know and you
know that you can trust these these high
numbers to indicate that global warming
is real at least in Vegas
um
it was multiple efficiency
oh which uh which family of classifiers
I don't remember probably around the
first
very simple these are
um
these are
um just numeric measurements it's like
temperature for hours temperature wind
direction and wind speed humidity just a
bunch of numbers so it's just a 8 or 10
dimensional numerical vector and I don't
remember like a small decision through
this probably the base
so
um
and then I just want to emphasize again
that this is uh taking Notions from
fairness and from supervised learning
taking them to like unsupervised
learning showing some I think surprising
results and uh some other authors then
took these inequalities that we proved
and or a subset of the authors that I'm
not part of but in future work and they
showed
um interesting properties in the
supervised learning again so there is a
fruitful back and forth between these
two worlds
all right thank you
certainly interest of time let's uh just
move on
foreign